hello and welcome to this video playing
mutters hmm
he says hi okay I can I say maybe me and
maybe I know him but I have not played
him and the cello I think so playing the
fried chick lying again and see what
happens
yeah he came no no it's e6 it's not a
fantastic line but it definitely takes
people out of book to play a game
straight away hmm I would have thought
he has to take a now he has taken
I think I'm driving this as well and
prepare Queen c5 trying to get the Queen
away from the quite dominant position on
on the forum yeah that looks like the
right choice
um I think probably this one for we
should be 7 next White's player might be
based on the idea f4 f5 in this case I
would have a queen square 25 even though
it is a very lucky kind of position
maybe e 505 okay if I am there will be
five our play too quickly okay so I'm
not saying that this is bad for white or
something but I think he five was more
critical
okay so what to do him I probably hmm I
don't know I don't like to take but B
492 doesn't feel all that brilliant edom
I probably have Jim yeah you can put the
night f4d form they both look they both
look him quite good if I somehow would
manage to oh that's interesting
is it any good though I mean what
exactly is the point I don't think he
wants to trade Queens I mean this just
helps me Queen over somewhere can it
should him should would like to to to be
sixes what I was thinking I'm not not
sure
maybe just g8 or something you just
asked me if this is a video
yep okay so I'm not sure she ain't I
can't go h5 for chief forward this is
probably just weakening myself
I'm just weakening my own position so
don't want to take this is more of a
waiting move than anything maybe I can
one idea was that I can potentially take
and play rook to e5 [ __ ] yeah it's an
idea at least he's got 93 down the back
takes another night X would be 593 I can
also take material I mean that's not
totally totally bonkers maybe I could
take night eggs take a five I mean but
it doesn't look it does not look right
another book on the first rank
for total business mail that maybe it
irritates them
and really a strange strange move maybe
94 still
I have no clue really what's going on
him okay
just checking the spawn and h5 looks
weird weird and wrong hmm
yeah Butchie fire firmly was a fairly
strange idea neither for my age 5 I'm
sorry are playing this badly 94 is just
takes excellent threatens 93 and I - 5
for my god ah what a bad position time
warning yeah I'm not even sure if I can
avoid my queen being trapped from the
knot
yeah that's the danger I'm playing those
kind of risky openings against someone
who knows stuff and at age five and I
resign wow what a terrible position
yeah well what did that take like half a
year just completely over yeah okay
black reason it was all played by white
and very badly played by me I mean I
actually think I must be okay after
Queen f1 I mean can you afford a strange
move but yeah okay the engine now
suggests to just basically cut this
Gordian knot and just take everything
this just looks so absolutely atrocious
this kind of position and it says equal
yeah maybe I have to maybe have to do
that but it absolutely sucks yeah you
know I didn't have a really clear idea
what to do this was maybe is still okay
and this is just doesn't it just doesn't
work I mean I'm just losing now and this
I cannot do anything here Ruby five was
the kind of both if just two totally
brain-dead move I really don't know what
the thing is this is absolutely I
absolutely have never played this kind
of position with with this pawn mattheum
I'm completely completely out of my wits
in the computer wants to take which
looks crazy opening opening up the e
foam yeah well okay I kind of you know
if you see it and the engine sends like
zero did you tend to say okay what what
what doing why didn't that play that but
okay this is just terrible it took it
took a while even to do it I just had no
clue what what's going on here yeah
after that it's overnight f4 to D 3 and
I can this wasn't exactly helping but it
is just losing anyway I cannot I mean
this position is also completely lost
cannot cannot save this anymore it spans
beyond beyond repair okay next time some
other line against much as thanks for
watching